martin mauis has returned to haiti after
receiving treatment in the united states
for wounds sustained during the
assassination of her husband
president giovannel moyes earlier this
month the interim prime minister claude
joseph
met her at the airport it's still not
clear whether he'll continue to run the
country
or who ordered the killing
they cannot destabilize me the plot is
very big
there are many people involved do not
create confusion about the clues
if you want let them assassinate me or
continue the investigation until its
conclusion
more than 20 colombian mercenaries
allegedly carried out the killing
most of whom were captured three were
killed
in this integrated work there is very
important data in terms of how the
homicide was carried out
and confirms that the initial meetings
were held in miami between people who
worked for the ctu security service
colombian investigators point the finger
at former haitian government official
felix badior whose whereabouts are
unknown
one of the few certainties in an
otherwise confused picture
is that the funeral for the former
president will take place
in the northern city of kapatien the
assassination came after weeks of rising
gang violence
fed by poverty and political corruption
exacerbated by the kovit-19 pandemic
the united nations last week delivered
the first half a million doses so haiti
can finally begin
its vaccination program
yes i see that we have started well we
have made awareness work with the staff
and went to the clinics to explain what
the disease is
and how to protect patients against it
officials have warned that the figure of
less than 500 dead and 19 000 infected
is probably under underreported and
inoculating haiti's 11 million
population
will be an uphill struggle
of course do you see what's going on in
the markets if everyone goes to the
public market
sitting next to each other it will be
the end of haiti
i think that we should vaccinate
everyone
but until that can happen others are
taking alternative measures
like the three-day annual pilgrimage to
bathe in the sacred waters
at the shrine of one of haiti's most
revered saints
our lady of mount carmel
daniel schweinler al jazeera